Hey, guys. Welcome back to the Channel.
If you're new here,
my name's Dami, and I am an architect
in beautiful Vancouver, B.C..
Today, we're going to be doing something
a little bit different.
We are going to be looking
at a couple of my favorite sci fi movies
that have really interesting
architectural concepts.
This video is sponsored by HP.
We'll talk about my keyboard
set up later in this video.
So the very first movie
that we're watching is Ex Machina,
which is a great movie.
If you guys haven't watched it.
And the storyline is about this,
a software engineer.
He wins a lottery to do an experiment
at the House of this,
his CEO of his company,
who's the cross between Jeff
Bezos and Elon Musk and Steve Jobs.
And he created this A.I., this Android.
And the main character
is basically going to his house to perform
the modern version of a Turing test
to see if this A.I.
can pass as a human.
Everything takes place in one house.
We'll kind of go over the house
in a little bit,
but it's a really fascinating movie
if you haven't watched it.
So he arrives at this very foreign
landscape.
He's already kind of thrown
into this very ambiguous situation.
So I just go down the path
and he's like, Where is the path?
I like how
it transitions from super, super, super
loud and hectic to silent.
The house is very discreet.
It's kind of hidden in the bushes,
very mysterious.
And this is actually a real building,
by the way.
It's a hotel in Norway.
Yeah, the entire movie is shot inside
this hotel.
The house itself
almost becomes a character.
His first encounter with
the CEO is actually his house.
The house says a lot about the person.
Actually, this cladding, if I'm not
mistaken, is a pine treated pine cladding.
Peter Zumthor
actually uses this in his home and office.
The color of the cladding,
I think, adds to the dark tone.
You know, it's not the light wood color.
And you have this incredibly
heavy metal door,
the door is the connection
between the outside and inside.
And I think the weight of the door
has a really big impact
on how you perceive the space
when you go inside.
And so it's already
creating this sense of mystery.
This detail is really nice here,
where the glass meets the stone,
the original architect
of the real building said they really,
really try
to focus on minimal intervention
to the site, and that's their approach
to sustainability.
This detail really speaks
to that philosophy.
They're saying, no, we're not going
to touch the existing site.
We're going to transform our building,
cut the glass
to meet all the jagged edges
of the existing stone.
And you can see this detail
in Fallingwater by Frank Lloyd
Wright as well, which is probably
one of the most iconic integration
of architecture into nature.
Floor to ceiling, glass everywhere.
I think there's a really clever
use of glass in this entire movie.
You've never been
outside this building.
you've never walked outside?
I've never been outside
the room I am in now.
It really confuses you.
Sometimes it's almost impossible
to tell who's
the subject of the experiment
and who is the experimenter.
And it also talks about a contrast
between confinement and freedom.
The scene is interesting, too,
because I think this tree
has something very symbolic to this movie.
When you're downstairs in the basement,
you have this very manicured
landscape, this little pot
with these two little trees.
And upstairs you have this expansive
nature all around you.
Like if you compare
the use of glass upstairs to downstairs
upstairs,
the glass is used to enclose the space,
but at the same time provide views
to this expansive forest and to this lake.
And you can look out into the mountains.
And then downstairs,
the glass is used to confine you.
Actually, the original building
has frosted glass throughout
and I think they use CGI
to make it transparent.
Or maybe they created a new set
for those in the real building.
They're using the frosted glass
to create a create privacy
and create a sense of relaxation
and calmness.
By turning all of the glass transparent,
you're able to see everything.
So it's creating an
environment of surveillance.
five years ago, building on the research
of our predecessors at the Institute,
my team and I discovered a process
by which all organic material
can be reduced at the cellular level
by a ratio
of approximately 2744 to 1.
Downsizing is a sci fi comedy drama,
and it's a movie that I like very much,
although it got pretty bad
reviews on Rotten Tomatoes,
I think it's really funny and smart.
So a group of scientists
invent this method
where you shrink the human body
into something about five inches.
And this was their solution
to climate change and overpopulation.
By downsizing, you consume less material
and you in turn help the earth.
I hold here in my hand
all of the compostable waste
produced by 36 people over four years.
The story is about Paul
Matt Damon, who,
you know, in his dire hours
kind of going through a midlife crisis,
decides to go through this procedure
and it's a non reversible.
One of the benefits of downsizing, of
course, is that you can take your savings
and when you apply that to your downsized
life, your money,
because everything is so small, becomes
like millions and millions of dollars.
And so you can live this very,
very lavish life in this tiny community.
And so, Paul,
he decides to go through this procedure
with his wife, but when he actually
shrinks himself, he ends up alone
because his wife ends up ditching him.
Last minute,
I thought this movie
was really interesting
because it's focused inwards,
not outwards.
Like whenever we talk about
the climate crisis or of overpopulation,
we're trying to change a bunch of things
in our environments.
We're trying to build denser, we're trying
to build faster to house more people.
But I really wonder what that process
was like for them to start researching.
Like, none of these solutions are working.
We have to like drastically change
something about ourselves.
This really reminded me of this book
that I read called Learning to Die
in the Anthropocene.
In this book,
the author, who's a war veteran,
he lists out in detail
all the problems that we have.
And he lists so in detail
all the solutions that we've created,
so renewable energy, solar, geothermal.
And he outlines why none of these
solutions are ever going to work.
And we are basically screwed
unless we drastically change
the way we live
and the way we think and philosophically,
like die as civilizations
and as individuals.
And in this case, that drastic change
was their physical change,
the shrunk their size.
What's more interesting and more ironic
is they've basically combined
the most sustainable solution
with the most unsustainable
form of urban development, urban sprawl.
All of these houses are,
you know, the American Dream mansions,
and they're these massive
gated communities, and they basically
shrunk themselves so that they can consume
as little as possible,
so that they can live the lavish lifestyle
that they've always wanted to live.
In the end, they're not really changing
anything about themselves.
They're just changing their size.
Yeah, it's
kind of ironic and kind of messed up
because the first part of the movie
is them like
contemplating whether they should go
through the procedure or not.
And do you understand that there exists
an approximately one in 225,000 chance
that the procedure could result in injury,
permanent disability or death?
When you look at
modern developments and ideas of healthier
living and healthier cities,
it's denser, like denser communities
with where everything is walkable
and everything is bikeable.
But it really makes you think
if you had all the money in the world
and if you had millions
and millions of dollars to spend, would
we still be trying
to build these dense societies,
or will we just be sprawling out
everywhere?
As an architect and a YouTuber.
I type a lot and I mean a lot.
Having a good typing
experience is really important to me.
And the new HP 975 dual mode wireless
keyboard
is really giving me a pretty premium
typing experience.
It's a wireless keyboard
with backlighting, which I consider
absolutely essential
for typing in different light conditions.
And you can connect up to three devices
at the same time.
All you need to do is press
the dedicated button to switch
between all your peripherals seamlessly.
The keys are quiet and comfortable,
and I really love that
the keyboard has a full size
number pad on the right side,
which makes it so much easier
when you're doing calculations
or working with spreadsheets.
The keyboard can detect when your hands
are coming closer to the keys
and turns on the backlight and the battery
can last weeks without a single charge.
If you need more customization,
you can use the HP app
to custom assign
more than 20 keys on your personal needs.
This keyboard is made with recycled
plastic and packaged
with 100% recycled paper
as a part of HP commitment
to producing sustainable products.
Follow the link in the description if you
want to learn more about this keyboard.
So the next one is a Japanese science
fiction manga
made by Tsutomo Nihei,
who was actually trained in architecture.
He actually went to Parson
Design School in New York,
but after working in construction
for a little bit,
he decided to leave architecture
and become a manga artist.
So Netflix recently
made a movie adaptation of the manga,
but I'm not going to talk about that.
I'm going to focus more
on the manga itself because I feel like
the movie adaptation wasn't
really respectful to the original work.
So his background in architecture
is really, really, really obvious
and his manga, there's very little dialog
and you really just understand the story
looking through the different environments
that he creates.
So the entire manga is this character
Kili, who
we have very, very little background on,
and he says very little.
And it's just him
just wandering and wandering
and wandering through the city,
which is constantly expanding.
So they're trying to find this
net terminal gene
and they're just trying to get away
from the city's defenses,
which is these robots and silicones
trying to attack them.
So all these images
make you feel very small
and lost and it's really vast in scale.
And you can see why he took
a lot of inspiration from brutalist
architecture, you know,
which is designed with that intent.
It's designed with the idea that communal
is more important than the individual.
So the timeline of his career is like
he was in architecture school
and then he did construction
for a very little time,
and then he decided to become manga
artist.
Actually, the skills that you learn
in architecture school,
I feel is closer to being a manga artist
or animation than actual construction.
We learn
all these graphic tools
to represent spaces
and it's really a parent that he has
an architectural background because that's
how you represent your projects.
You represent them through spaces,
not through people or dialog.
I think the interesting is
that when you're designing in school,
you're designing spaces for people,
not spaces that are hostile for people.
I think his perspective is really unique,
not just in the stylistic way
he creates his work, but
also in the storylines that he creates.
Because I think a lot of architects,
the design buildings,
they don't necessarily design
the buildings through the person's eyes.
So as a manga artist,
I feel like you're working
with a lot of emotions with architecture.
Were really working in the realm of beauty
and proportion,
and we rarely try to bring in emotion
into our spaces or images,
although we should.
And I think
even though there's very little dialog
and very little character development,
that is the one point of connection
that you feel with the characters,
the feeling of like being lost
and alone in the space.
As you're flipping through these images.
I think it's really interesting
that he borrowed so much from Brutalism,
and I think if architecture
was to become alive,
brutalist architecture
would be the type
that would want to destroy humans.
It's the most foreboding
and dominant style of building,
and I think it's really fitting
that he used this
in a storyline.
So Elysium is about a dystopian society
based and in the future, around 2154, it's
by a South African director that actually
has a huge influence on the movie.
And I think he's trying
to recreate this society in South Africa
where the see these huge divides
between rich and poor.
I think the movie has an opportunity
to be a real social commentary,
but I think what's more interesting about
the movie is
the realism of the environment
that he creates.
The entire world has become a third world.
Yeah.
So all these housing, it's
very organic development.
It's very similar to favelas.
Favelas are informal developments.
Basically,
there is no rules and it was just
built purely out of necessity
by the inhabitants living there.
You're like,
This is favelas at a massive scale.
Yeah.
You can also see like little houses
on top of buildings.
And that's actually
what's happening in places like Hong Kong,
like they have these rooftop slums
and thousands of people
are living in them
because they just don't have enough space.
And then Elysium is a satellite community,
like a literal satellite
community that's orbiting around the Earth
and all the rich people
who could afford to move there.
And it's in the shape of a circle.
It's very finite.
It's kind of like saying we can only fit
in a certain amount of people here.
And you can see that
a lot of the structures that you see
in Elysium are more fluid and organic.
They try to make this Elysium
really realistic as possible
and really tried to think about
the construction that went behind it.
And you can see that
a lot of these are in modules
and a lot of the panels are in sizes
that are, you know, realistic enough.
But you can transport them from Earth
to space.
You know,
modular construction is the future.
Once we start find tuning prefabrication
and the ability to design
and fabricate things offsite and
bring them on site just to be assembled,
that's going to make construction
so much more efficient.
It's going to cut errors, it's
going to cut costs.
We're going to be able
to save so much materials and labor.
We just need a couple more years
to get there.
In this scenario, like in space,
you kind of have to do modular
construction like
you can't really have any room for errors.
This kind of necessitates
this modular construction.
So there's a really interesting book
called Refabricating Architecture
by Stephen Kieran from Kieran Timberlake.
He compares architecture to industries
like car manufacturing
or aerospace manufacturing.
He looks at how efficient
those manufacturing systems are,
and by adopting those methodologies,
we can really, really, really improve
a lot of the processes, like
not just in construction, but all the way
from design to processing to manufacturing
to the operation of the building.
We're going to need a new architect.
So Inception is a story about this thief
whose job is to go into the dreams
of these CEOs and steal corporate secrets.
The architect in
this case is really important
because they designed the environments
for these dreams
to make the dreamer believe
that it's their dream.
Now, imagine
you're designing a building, right?
You consciously create each aspect,
but sometimes it feels like
it's almost creating itself,
if you know what I mean.
Yeah, like I'm discovering
genuine inspiration, right?
A lot of the things that they're saying
is really accurate
to the process of design.
A lot of the times
when you start designing,
you don't really know
what it's going to look like.
And so as you go
through these different options
and through different sketches and models,
you'll see what works
and what doesn't work
and you'll see
where the design wants to go.
So it's really
like a process of discovery, I guess.
I thought that the dream space
would be all about the visual, but
it's more about the feel..
I am lying on polyester...
I am not lying on my carpet in my apartment.
A dream is not about visuals.
It's really more about the sensation.
And I really appreciate that
they added this little detail in here
because I feel like that will be something
that will be really difficult to convey
in a movie, because a movie
is a very visual experience.
When you dream, it really
is more about a feeling actually,
the other day I just had a dream
where I was at my old high school,
but the surrounding was a beach
and there was a winding path
to the high school and beyond the beach,
like I could see the beautiful sunset
and there was a cliff
and it wasn't really
any of the details of the school.
It was just the sensation.
And so in your waking life,
this is very different
because it's much more focused
on our visual senses.
It's not really a recent phenomena,
but I feel like as we spend more time
on our phones and our screens, we do spend
much, much, much more time in the 2D.
It's much more of a visual experience
rather than a sensory experience.
And this actually leads to what we call
experiential impoverishment.
I actually talk about this
in my other video.
I'll leave the link right here
when we dream.
Our brains are much, much,
much more active
and it's able to perceive things
more holistically.
It can perceive things
with smell, sight, touch, taste.
And I think that's why we're able
to recreate these environments
so much faster
than when we're drawing in real life
in architecture,
it's actually called haptic architecture.
It's when you incorporate
all of these different senses
into your spatial experience.
You know, we should really all
be designing for all of these senses.
But when you design for your haptics,
not just your visual,
as it makes your experience of the space
and your memory of the space much,
much stronger, and it really solidifies
that space in your mind.
I'm sure there's tons of other good movies
with great architectural concepts.
If you have any suggestions,
let me know in the comments.
And I think I'll definitely
try to make a part two of this videos
because I had a lot of fun.
If you're interested in learning more
about architecture,
I'll leave a playlist
of my personal favorites right here.
I also have a monthly newsletter
where I share my insights and things
that I'm learning or reading or listening
to, as well as a Discord Channel
where you can chat with other people
in this amazing community.
And if you want to support the channel
and listen in on interviews by me
with other industry professionals
as well as access to other perks,
I do have membership tiers
that you can join.
I'm going to leave links to all of this
in the description of this video,
and with that,
I'll see you in the next one.
Wait,
you're not leaving me here?
Can you understand how I feel?
I feel terrible.
I let you down. I feel awful.
But then I realize I was just doing this
because I was trying to make you happy.
And I should have been thinking
more about myself.
When you're dreaming, you're
using all of these different faculties,
not just your visuals.
And again, I think that's why you're able
to recreate these environments
so much faster than real life.
This video
this video is sponsored by short form.
This video is sponsored by Autodesk.
This video is sponsored by
what was your refresh?
This video is sponsored by Hellofresh.
More on that later.
More on them later
and more on them later.
We thought at the end
this video is sponsor.
More on them later.
More on that later. More on them later.
This video is sponsored by Pacific Ark.
This video is sponsored by Autodesk.
More on them later.
They just want to go Pacific, Ark.
This video is sponsored by Ace Lab.
More on them later.
This video is sponsored by Pacific Ark.
This video is sponsored by Islam.
More on them later.
Best way to convey the contrast
between the favelas
and these informal housing.
And Elysium.
Here is that there's
no wall between the dining room
and the toilet.
And yeah.
So if you have guests over for dinner
and you have to pee,
well, you're out of luck.
I think the first luxury that goes
when you're live in poverty
is probably privacy.
And I think this space, this apartment
actually creates a pretty strong
narrative of what's happening because it's
actually a pretty large space.
It's probably somewhere around like 400
square feet, but it's not well-designed.
It was just put together out of necessity
because someone needed space ASAP.
Yeah, it tells a story of a city
and a population that's been abandoned.
You know, there's like no building codes
saying
there needs to be a wall
between the toilet and the dining room.
And there's, like,
no jurisdiction cracking down on the
basic spatial constraints.
I like how
even in the future for the mega,
mega rich,
they still have like very conventional
looking
kind of Victorian style houses,
but with circles, circular windows.
So the entire movie takes place
in one building in this
this house of the CEO and the upstairs.
You have views everywhere.
And I think it's just so fascinating
how just by using these two floors
and using glass, it's able to create
so many different scenarios
with a little skylight.
But that's pretty much
your only connection to nature.
The basement is where the A.I.,
the Android
and the test subject are living.
So it's a pretty big contrast
and it creates these
two worlds.
It's floor to ceiling glass.
You can see the mountains and the trees
and the downstairs basement.
There's no windows.
There's this little garden with
these trees.
I think this lens
flare here is pretty intentional.
And you can see that in a lot of
the scenes that's taking place upstairs.
There's a lot
of like lens flare and light.